[Musique]
à quelques jours du coup d'envoi de la
11e édition des Jeux des îles à
Madagascar le département de La Réunion
a souhaité rendre hommage au pionnier de
ces jeux qui ont ouvert le bal lors de
la toute première édition qui s'est
déroulée sur notre île en 1979 ce
vendredi 11 août une cérémonie de remise
de prix était organisée dans l'hémicycle
du Palais de la source en présence du
président du cross et des représentants
de la région et du préfet sportif et
mérite dirigeant de clubs entraîneurs
mais aussi journalistes en tout ils
étaient 60 à se voir décerner le prix
départemental du Mérite depuis 44 ans
se sont passées de nouvelles disciplines
se sont développées la pratique du sport
cette démocratiser et nous sommes fiers
de voir que la Réunion Corée à travers
les performances de nos jeunes
Réunionnais
nous avons voulu honorer les pionniers
ce celles et ceux qui étaient là au
départ
des championnes et des champions qui
chacune et chacun dans sa discipline à
ses proches bien le sport si l'obtention
de médailles d'or d'argent ou de bronze
a constitué le principal critère de
mérite pour ce prix le département a
également souhaité honoré celles et ceux
qui ont continué à s'investir dans la
vie sportive et associative de l'île
d'abord évidemment qu'on est extrêmement
ému parce qu'on a eu un accueil
extraordinaire et se remémorer un peu
comme ça les anciens qui ont construit
le sport parce que moi pour ma part j'ai
été au jeu des ulules c'est évident
c'était symbolique mais après j'ai fait
toute ma carrière dans le sport donc
j'ai 50 ans de sport derrière moi aussi
bien en tant qu'athlète dirigeant et
professionnel du sport et on est obligé
de saluer de remercier l'initiative il
fait à moins l'honneur parce que
ça me rappelle quand j'étais jeune
premièrement j'ai fait des îles le
trophée mais j'oublie jamais que j'étais
avec les copains on a joué bien avec
mais pour aller en sélection on peut pas
mettre tout le monde mais c'est grâce à
mes copains des clubs que la progressé
une cérémonie aux aires de retrouvailles
festive 44 ans après c'est tout premiers
jeux qui ont laissé une trace dans
l'histoire du sport local et auront
permis depuis de faire naître des
vocations chez de nombreux jeunes 79 a
été
un tremplin pour le sport annionnaire en
ce sens que nous passions de
disciplines au maximum 13 jeux à 77
ligues et comités aujourd'hui organisés
donc à travers plusieurs milliers de
clubs et de sport étonnés donc a connu
une évolution considérable un héritage
extraordinaire grâce à ses premiers Jeux
de 79 les élus et les visiteurs ont
d'ailleurs pu s'imprégner de l'ambiance
de l'époque en découvrant une exposition
photo signée Claude testa une série de
clichés uniques que les visiteurs
pourront admirer jusqu'au vendredi 25
août sous le hall du palais de la source
[Musique]